the 1988 comedy classic big follows a
kid named Josh who magically morphs into
a 30 year old man at first this
transformation seems pretty cool
especially when Josh has paid big bucks
to play with toys for a living but the
things get problematic when he starts
dating Susan his adult co-worker
[Music]
Tom Hanks and Elizabeth Perkins are
about the same age in real life but in
the movie Josh is actually only 12. so
when the two end up sleeping together
we're witnessing a serious felony
offense even though Susan doesn't yet
know about Josh's Condition it's hard to
wrap your head around true but it's
undeniably creepy at the end when Josh
reversed to his child form and grown
woman Susan waves goodbye to her 12 year
old ex-boyfriend